[Musik]
53 schauspieler die die korona politik
der bundesregierung in diesen videos
hier kritisieren das können sie gut
finden das können sie schlecht finden
aber sind diese videos wirklich ein
skandal sind die eine verhöhnung aller
corona kranken und corona toten in
diesem land so dass diese schauspieler
mittlerweile reihenweise ihre videos
wieder zurückgezogen haben aus angst
weil sie schutzlos ausgesetzt sind und
sogar mittlerweile morddrohungen wie
weit kann und darf corona kritik in
diesem land überhaupt noch gehen die
richtigen fragen jetzt live bei bild ja
wieviel corona kritik wie viel corona
streit vertragen wir eigentlich in
diesem land darüber wollen wir jetzt
streiten nämlich mit diesen gästen mit
der ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern manuela schwesig
mit lisa federle der tübinger notärztin
und pandemie beauftragten dort und mit
albert wyler dem
cdu-bundestagsabgeordneten der sich doch
tatsächlich getraut hat im bundestag
gegen das infektionsschutzgesetz
zustimmen obwohl seine fraktion das
mehrheitlich nicht wollte
in allen einen schönen guten abend ja
wir streiten auch über diese videos
dieser prominenten schauspieler die seit
tagen ja deutschland fast den atem
halten muss man sagen mein name ist die
an josef liefers ich bin schauspieler
und ich möchte heute danke sagen hallo
ich bin richy müller ich bin
schauspieler und mache mir sehr große
sorgen mein name ist momentan gering ich
bin schon da aber das tut nichts zur
sache wir sitzen
kanal im gleichen boot wir sollten
einfach nur allem zustimmen und tun was
man uns sagt mein name ist christian
sommer und ich bin martin brambach und
wenn man sich sieht kann man sich
anstecken und deswegen habe ich alle
meine kontakte von meinem telefon
gelöscht
damit schütze ich mich aber auch andere
vor möglichen kontakten das letzte jahr
war schwer
ich habe mich ständig daran erinnert wie
das leben vorher war
und manchmal habe ich was vermisst aber
das lässt jetzt nach deswegen haben wir
eine strategie entwickelt zum einatmen
den wölfen ins schlafzimmer und zum
ausatmen is more thing auf diese art
atmen hier
wir wollen immer saubere luft ein
bleiben sie gesund verzweifeln sie ruhig
aber zweifeln sie nicht so spießig
finden sie diese aktion gelungen
ich mache mir große sorgen um unser land
wir müssen aufpassen dass unser land
zusammenbleibt wir erleben ja viel
zerrissenheit auch vor ort die einen die
sagen das was ihr macht politik das
reicht doch nicht macht das ganze land
dicht wir müssen noch stärker
runterkommen und andere die eben sagen
jetzt muss auch mal schluss sein nach
einem jahr so geht es nicht mehr weiter
und deshalb liegt mir sehr am herzen
dass wir wirklich versuchen das land
zusammenzuhalten es ist völlig klar dass
nach einem jahr alle durch sind dass
alle am limit sind und ganz besonders
natürlich auch die die ganz stark unter
dieser krise leiden
was mir ich habe zwei punkte die mir
gefehlt also die ich finde an dieser
stelle problematischen kein wort zu den
pflegekräften zu den ärzten die am limit
sind
wir machen das ja nicht aus jux und
dollerei sondern wir haben ein echtes
problem die leute in den
intensivstationen arbeiten seit einem
jahr hart und das darf nicht in den
hintergrund rücken und ist zweite ich
finde die kritik dass wir nicht offen
transparent und kontrovers diskutieren
die ist echt ich berechtigt ich meine
auf allen sendern auch bei ihnen bei
bild diskutieren wir doch jeden tag die
verschiedenen sichtweisen der
wissenschaftler der politik und das sind
zwei punkte
die ich überhaupt nicht teilen kann und
trotzdem wäre mir wichtig anhand dieser
gesamten debatte der letzten tage dass
wir alle daran denken unser land muss
zusammenbleiben
es hat sich niemand dieses virus
ausgedacht wir können es auch nicht
ausknipsen
aber das sei ist der rheinland soll
zusammenhalten soll zusammenbleiben das
bedeutet doch dass man trotzdem
unterschiedlicher meinung sein soll also
finden sie dass diese schauspieler diese
53 mit ihren videos eher gespalten haben
ich sehe ja dass wir eine heftige
diskussion haben und sowohl die
befürworter der maßnahmen erleben ja
seit vielen monaten denken sie an karl
lauterbach an andere dass sie
angefeindet werden dass sie bedroht
werden und auch diejenigen die das jetzt
so kritisieren erleben das gleiche und
mir war wichtig dass wir in der sache
diskutieren auch die einzelnen maßnahmen
und was sich zurückweise ist und das hat
ja gerade jan josef liefers sehr stark
gemacht das ist eben keine angeblich
alle untertanen sind es gebe keine
kontroverse debatte alle folgen der
regierung dass es stimmt doch überhaupt
nicht geht es gut hier in jeden tag alle
maßnahmen hoch und runter auf die
wissenschaftler diskutieren kontrovers
also diese kontroverse diskussion gibt
es doch und die sollten wir auch weiter
führen aber sachlich und in respekt und
wir sollten niemals die vergessen die
nicht zur zeit sichtbar sind das sind
die pfleger die ärzte mit denen ich
gesprochen habe und die sagen wir sind
am limit wir brauchen diese maßnahmen
wir können das gesundheitssystem nicht
ausreizen und schon gar nicht überlasten
die pfleger und die ärzte und ärztin
frau federle notärztin in tübingen und
von anfang an an der korona front
sozusagen
es gibt die kritik an diesen
schauspielern die auch darauf zielt dies
sei eine verhöhnung all derer die diesen
dienst leisten all der korona kranken
auch und der korona toten
beziehungsweise ihrer angehörigen fühlen
sie sich als jemand der dort im chor
ohne einsatz täglich ist verhöhnt durch
diese videos nein aber ich fühle mich
deswegen nicht verwöhnt
weil ich weiß was damit gemeint war also
ich glaube dass keiner von denen diese
absicht hatte irgendjemand zu verhöhnen
und gerade speziell mit jan josef
liefers aber endlich eigentlich seit
wochen sogar noch länger schon zusammen
da hat er uns in thirring unterstützt
mit dem modellprojekt in tübingen und
ich bin gerade sogar dabei eine auszeit
zwei wochen für kinder was mit ihm
zusammen auf die beine zu stellen mit ob
reporter und noch mit anderen die da
sich engagieren wollen weil das die
vergessenen sehen in der krise gerade
sind und dass ich sag jetzt mal
übertrieben die sterben langsam kleine
stelle tot
über die niemand redet und ich glaube es
war eher so in die richtung gedacht das
stilmittel ist sicher nicht ganz passend
und natürlich kann ich auch menschen
verstehen die sich da angegriffen oder
veraltet oder einfach nicht
wertgeschätzt fühlen aber ich glaube so
wird es auch manuela schwesig gesagt hat
ja es zeigt auf wie gespalten die
gesellschaft ist und was mir persönlich
angst macht wie aggressiv die
gesellschaft auch teilweise es also nur
als beispiel die leute die jetzt jan
josef liefers zujubeln also sprich afd
oder in die richtung die gleichen
bedrohen mich und manchmal habe ich das
gefühl es geht auch gar nicht mehr
tatsächlich um corona oder nicht corona
sondern es geht darum seinen ganzen
brass und ärger und seine aggression im
netz einfach abzuladen
und das ist schon bedenklich weil du
kannst es niemand recht machen kannst
auch eigentlich schreiben und sagen was
du willst du wirst immer angegriffen wie
werden sie bedroht frau federle wir
leben sie bedrohung also attila hildmann
zum beispiel hat ganz klar mich bedroht
da ist auch die report dahinter da gibt
es auch anzeigen und so weiter das ist
aber ich habe auch mal zu
durch anonyme briefe bekommen ich habe
auch an russischen bekommen
so nach dem motto ich würde dir die welt
zu testen und die nächste die dass man
nicht mehr erleben würde wäre ich und
solche dinge also daran mag ich auch wie
es den menschen geht ich meine ich habe
ein gewisses verständnis dass die leute
mit der situation nicht mehr zurecht
kommen aber ich glaube das ist auch ein
ganz ganz wichtiger punkt in der politik
dass wir das jetzt hingegen die wieder
einzusammeln ja auf beiden seiten die
einen die totale panik kam und sich
daheim verbarrikadieren und die anderen
die sagen das ist alles quatsch
das stimmt nicht und ist sie wir haben
alle unterdrückt und ihnen wurden chip
eingepflanzt oder sonst irgendwas herr
weiler kennen auch sie diese bedrohungen
sie haben sich gerade exponiert in der
vergangenen woche dadurch dass sie an
einer der wenigen waren in der unions
fraktion jetzt schon gesagt die gegen
das infektionsschutzgesetz gestimmt
haben haben sie auch ja vielleicht nicht
so nette briefe bekommen am 7 drohungen
erhalten
bedrohungen hab ich jetzt in dem sinne
nicht erhalten aber schon eine gewisse
art auch von von würde ich mal sagen
mobbing als es waren schon einige auch
von von kollegen die dann mich anfangs
schon ein bisschen geschnitten haben
das hat sich mittlerweile alles wieder
alles wieder gelegt bedrohungen habe ich
nicht bekommen
aber die frage ist wie gehen wir jetzt
mit dem weiler um der hat die kanzlerin
angeschrieben er hat die
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidentin
angeschrieben hat das gesagt was das
volk eigentlich so denkt ich habe es ja
nur weitergegeben
und ja man müsste nicht mit mir
umzugehen mittlerweile weisen die video
ist jetzt der 53 schauspieler herr
weiter wie welches echo finden die bei
ihnen den thüringen dort in saalfeld
also ärgert man sich eher über die
schauspieler oder ärgert man sich eher
über die sehr teilweise scharfe kritik
an den schauspielern
also ich arbeite auch mit vielen
schaustellern und auch künstlern
zusammen theater leuten usw
und die sagen dass meine meinung auch
das kabarett ismus in deutschland groß
geschrieben wird
und man diesen kabarettist muss erkennen
muss und auch nicht verteufeln darf wir
haben ja gesehen was wozu das führen
kann bei charlie abdo und dass wir das
jetzt mit den schauspielern gemacht
wurde die eigentlich nur kabarettist
muss machen wollten und ihr einfluss ist
vielleicht auch zeigen
das finde ich so nicht in ordnung
schauen wir noch mal einmal ganz kurz
rein in einen ausschnitt des videos der
prominenten schauspielerin heike
makatsch
hallo ich bin heike makatsch ich bin
schauspielerin hat geklingelt
aber ich mache nicht auf vielleicht ist
es lieferando vielleicht amazon dhl und
es macht mir große sorgen das ist da
draußen egoistische leute gibt die auf
machen wollen
ich mache immer noch nicht auf bleibt
sie gesund und machen sie auch nicht
haben
frau schwesig was an diesem video könnte
so unerträglich seien jetzt mal
abgesehen davon ob man das witzig findet
oder nicht aber was daran könnte so
unerträglich sein dass heike makatsch
kurz danach sofort wieder entschieden
hat das sofort wieder zu löschen das
video zurückzuziehen
ich glaube dass michael marx selbst
beantworten denn sie muss sich ja
gedanken gemacht haben warum sie bei der
aktion mitmacht und warum sie jetzt
zurückzieht was ich wahrgenommen habe
ist dass viele sich sehr erschrocken
haben wie auf einmal die querdenker
szene die rechte szene
diese videos feiert da muss ich aber
sagen das war vorhersehbar denn vieles
von dem ist ja sozusagen das was gerne
querdenker rechte bringen und jeden tag
sagen auf ihren demo sprechen und ich
bin ganz sicher dass viele dieser
künstler gar nichts mit dieser szene zu
tun haben im gegenteil wir wissen ja
dass sich viele gerade zum beispiel von
ihnen gegen rechtsextremismus engagieren
und das sind dinge wo sich jetzt
sicherlich einige auseinandergesetzt
haben aber ich kann das nicht
beantworten weil ich nicht weiß was die
beweggründe waren mitzumachen ob das
nicht gesehen wurden ist dass das
natürlich die folge hat und deswegen
noch mal mir wäre sehr wichtig dass wir
sachlich über diese dinge sprechen und
natürlich ist es nicht so dass kein
paket das man kein paket annehmen kann
das weiß jeder im gegenteil
das hat ja enorm zugenommen und mir wäre
einfach wichtig das ist jetzt eine zeit
wo alle am limit sind wo sowieso ganz
viele fake news auch unterwegs sind wo
dinge behauptet werden wo wir auch vor
ort uns immer wieder dagegen ankämpfen
dass falsche informationen unter die
leute gebracht werden
ob es zum thema schutzmaßnahmen oder
innen ist und deswegen ist es auch
wichtig in dieser zeit sehr sensibel zu
sein ich würde lieber den scheinwerfer
muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
auf ganz viele künstler und leute in der
veranstaltungsbranche werfen die zum
beispiel beim impfen mithelfen wie man
es in berlin sehen kann dass leute bei
der veranstaltung aus der
veranstaltungsbranche denen es auch
wirklich schlecht geht dort mithelfen
das stimmt nur noch mal zu der scharfen
kritik an diesen videos also wie gesagt
ob man das nur gut findet oder schlecht
findet er witzig findet oder nicht aber
den für schauspielerin jetzt vorzuwerfen
sie haben in ihren videos kein
vollständiges bild abgelieferte oder den
ton nicht getroffen wie gesagt wenn man
es selbst schlecht findet aber diese
kritik auf die konnte man doch nicht
verzichten weil man vielleicht
befürchten musste dass sich dass man da
instrumentalisiert wird aus der falschen
ecke oder dass man auch aus dem falschen
bereich applaus bekommt frau schwesig
ich denke schon dass man gerade in
dieser aufgewühlten zeit in dieser zeit
wo alle körperlich und
natürlich auch mit kopf vom geist am
limit sind weil wir alle wollen dass es
ein ende hat weil man sich irgendwie
wenn man morgens aufwacht wünscht dass
corona vorbei ist aber es ist nicht
vorbei wir müssen aufpassen dass gerade
in dieser sensiblen zeit der richtige
ton getroffen wird
denn es ist gerade auf gefühlte zeit und
da glaube ich stehen auch die
schauspieler da schon die künstler in
verantwortung weil sie ganz genau wissen
wie ihre worte ihre gesten wirken es
sind ja alles profis und ich sage
deswegen an der stelle noch mal von
allen seiten wir müssen wirklich das
land zusammenhalten
wir müssten abrüsten es sind jetzt noch
mal schwere wochen und wir sollten
darüber sprechen was ganz konkret getan
werden kann nun auch im bio rasieren
nochmal auf das abzubinden frosch wie
sehen sie haben die medizin in die
öffentlichkeit kommen sie haben
letztlich kein verständnis für die
aktion die hätten lieber still sein
sollen die schauspieler das habe ich
nicht gesagt ich habe gesagt dass es
wichtig ist dass man dass wir auf worte
gesten und inhalte achten müssen und
dass wir auch zusammen sein müssen und
dass ich eben kritikpunkte nicht teile
am meisten teile ich die nicht den
kritikpunkt dass es von jan josef
liefers dass es alle untertanen sind
dass es keine kontroverse oder
transparente debatte gibt ich meine
weise was machen sie denn jeden tag
es gibt doch die wissenschaftler hoch
und runter die einen sagen ist noch
strenger werden die anderen sagen das
ist übertrieben so ist es in der
bevölkerung so ist es in der politik so
es ist in allen teilen der gesellschaft
also dieser punkt dass wir nicht offen
und kritisch und kontrovers diskutieren
den kann ich überhaupt nicht teilen
darüber möchte ich jetzt auch sprechen
wissen sie ich versuche mich mit den
kritikpunkten auseinanderzusetzen
verstehe ich habe sie haben gleichzeitig
gesagt die form war nicht die richtige
es macht natürlich im moment vielleicht
lassen wir es bei den punkt federle noch
ganz kurz bleiben wie welche kritik
hätten's denn im moment kern für dich
dann wissen denn es ist ja nicht gehen
nicht gerade einfacher also man kann
nicht demonstrieren gehen auf der straße
man kann es schon aber viele sagen eben
unvernünftig dumm ich persönlich würde
es in dieser zeit im moment auch nicht
tun
es bleiben nicht so wahnsinnig viele
möglichkeiten erst recht wenn man
vielleicht schauspieler ist und man
genau diese
form der artikulation gelernt hat sich
dann entsprechend aus seinem genre
heraus zu äußern ohne dass man so einen
shitstorm erfährt federle
also ich finde es kann nicht sein dass
uns seine meinung äußert und ich meine
das war jetzt nicht eine total radikale
meinung es ist natürlich überzogen
gewesen ironisch zynisch aber man muss
in deutschland die meinung äußern können
und ohne dass man gleich bedroht oder an
gesäß eve unter druck gesetzt wird also
das finde ich das geht gar nicht
wenn ich wenn ich mir das überlegen das
was jetzt passiert ist das macht ja die
menschen unter umständen mundtot und es
ist ja schon so dass ein teil der
bevölkerung und das kann ich aus eigener
erfahrung sagen weil ein paar wissen ja
dass ich mit jan josef liefers ganz gut
befreundet bin ich bekomme jetzt von
teil der bevölkerung auch angriffe dass
ich das verteidigt habe wobei ich ich
hab gesagt ich kenne mich weißt warum
erst oder sagen wir mal so wie es
gemeint hat dass nämlich auf kinder das
einfach auf die problematik der
unsichtbaren auch aufmerksam machen
wollte aber ich bekomme genauso auch
wirklich mindestens genauso viel mails
von leuten die sagen sie finde es
grandios dass ich einfach laufen auch
hin gestanden bin und sie möchten dass
sich jan josef liefers das weiter gebe
also das zeigt einfach wie die
gesellschaft von ta gespalten ist und
ich finde man muss beide auch irgendwo
berücksichtigen und schätzen und auch
zusammenführen wie da ja und über diese
aktion frau federle ich möchte die runde
nochmal kurzarbeiter möchte ich jetzt
aussprechen mit dem filmproduzenten
regisseure und ufa chef nico hofmann der
dieser aktion in den vergangenen stunden
auch kritisiert hat schönen guten abend
der hoffmann
diarra genannt herr hofmann sie haben
diese aktion der 53 deutschen
prominenten schauspieler kritisiert sie
haben das eine steilvorlage für
antidemokratische kräfte genannt was
genau ist die steilvorlage was genau
halten sie für gefährlich muss zunächst
mal sagen ich war über viele wochen auch
involviert war mich viele kolleginnen
und kollegen angerufen haben ich habe
immer davor gewarnt dass diese art von
ironie von satire ein ganz schmaler grat
ist der wirklich von antidemokratischen
und auch rechten kräften ausgenutzt
werden kann
und es ist auch jetzt passiert also ist
er innerhalb weniger stunden auf diesen
plattformen dann entsprechend
kommentiert wurden
und das war für mich absehbar und das
hat mich geärgert weil es quasi
alarmstufe rot schon vor wochen war und
jetzt ist es genau so gekommen und viele
sind auch sehr betroffen darüber aber
man hat es vorher sich denken können
offen gestanden
aber was genau ist das gefährliche also
was genau ist das wovor sie gewarnt
haben möglicherweise haben sie auch
gesagt kommt macht es anders aber wie
hätte man es anders machen können und
was wie gesagt ist an dem ding genau
konkret gefährlich also ich glaube wenn
man jetzt mal wirklich sehr genau
auseinander nehmen müssen ja sehr sehr
verschiedene künstler und künstlerinnen
und sehr verschiedene beiträge und ich
bin auch nicht dann freund die sache
jetzt über einen kamm zu scheren also
wenn sie jan josef liefers kennen das
ist ein ganz ganz demokratischer kluger
politischer mensch aber die gesamt
stimulierung die das ganze hat also
dieser art zwischen ironie zynismus
distanzierungen kommentierung auch die
unterschiedlichkeit der qualität der
beiträge
das ist eine offene flanke für alle
rechtspopulisten für alle querdenker
sich ja quasi immer das segment
rauszupicken was jetzt gerade im moment
in diese antidemokratische stimmung und
diese diskussion führt und passt und das
ist im moment in einer sehr sehr
schwierigen angespannten gesamtlage ist
das toxisch und ich glaube das haben
viele mittlerweile auch erkannt haben
sie den kollegen insgesamt von der
kritik ab geraten oder von der art der
kritik nur von der art der kritik also
ich bin großer freunde diskussionskultur
bin ein großer freund auch offen sein
wort sagen zu können muss er immer
wieder sagen das ist ja
vielen vielen gedanken überlegungen bei
den künstlerinnen und künstlern eine
aktion gewesen auch auf den notstand
ihrer branche hinzuweisen dass es noch
immer wieder sagen das ist ein ganz
moralisch komplett hehrer und intakter
ansatz aber dann ist sprache form und
inhalt ist natürlich ausschlaggebend
und das ist in diesem fall sehr sehr aus
nutzbar gewesen es gibt jetzt weiterhin
heftige reaktionen gegenreaktion gegen
ein großteil dieser schauspieler ganz
aktuell sagt meret becker sie habe
morddrohungen erhalten würden sie an der
stelle sagen ich habe sie gewarnt selber
schuld nein das ist ganz schlimm
wir stehen jetzt hier auch werden heute
den großen versammlungstag der deutschen
filmakademie
ich bin für den deutschen filmpreis
mitverantwortlich in diesem jahr
ich kann nur alle bitten zu einer
grossen solidarität wieder
zurückzukehren
also auch jetzt rundfunkrede die jetzt
quasi berufsverbote fordern oder motto
rungen das ist absolut indiskutabel und
führt auch zu einer hass ort hier kann
man regen sagen die finde ich völlig
daneben und lernte so völlig ab ich
frage mich angesichts dessen nämlich ob
sie und viele kritiker dieser aktion
sehe ich aktuell das falsche ziel für
die kritik aussuchen denn die reaktionen
auf diese videos waren ja massiv auch
schon bei twitter bei facebook bei
instagram und haben jeden angemessenen
ton vermissen lassen das heißt müsste
man nicht viel schärfer diese art von
cic form von morddrohungen mittlerweile
kritisieren die kritisiere ich die finde
ich völlig indiskutabel das finde ich
ihn also indiskutabel wenn autos von
politikern in brand gesetzt werden wir
politisch nicht mit ihnen einverstanden
ist aber darf ich ihnen wirklich sagen
sie haben das zitat von mir in der bild
zeitung gedruckt es geht um
ausgewogenheit und um klarheit in der
formulierung und sie sprechen ja gerade
mit mir und es hat auch mit der
differenzierung zu tun ganz klare
antwort auf ihre frage dieses absolut
unmöglich werden schauspielerinnen und
schauspielern diese art und weise
angegriffen werden und ist komplett
unmöglich wenn rundfunkrede
berufsverbote fordern für
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler die
sich hier geäußert haben das geht gar
nicht und schon gar nicht im
demokratischen verbundsystem letzte
frage nico hofmann würden sie nach
dieser aktion aktuell
einmal länger nachdenken sie persönlich
als filmproduzent einen dieser 53
aktuell zu engagieren wenn sie heute
beispielsweise in ihrem kopf hätten
aktuellen film zu initiieren mit jan
josef liefers oder heike makatsch und so
weiter würden sie ein tick länger
überlegen oder wäre das völlig
unabhängig und er bekäme natürlich das
engagement würde ich keine sekunde zu
überlegen
sie müssen doch wissen da können sie
jetzt fast jeden einzelnen anrufen ich
habe mit 90 prozent gearbeitet die
letzten 20 jahre jan josef ist ein
großartiger mensch
ich würde uli tukur ich würde mir egal
wer heike makatsch ich würde keine
sekunde darüber nachdenken mit ihnen zu
arbeiten
ganz im gegenteil ich finde die die
grundvoraussetzung auch der diskussion
auch die lange lange zeit die sich alle
beteiligten überlegt haben das überhaupt
aktiv werden
das muss man erst mal respektieren in
der gesellschaft wie dieser also ganz
klare antwort keine sekunde würde ich
darüber nachdenken mit einem mit mit
irgend jemand aus der gruppe nicht zu
arbeiten ich würde mit jedem arbeiten
danke für das gespräch an den
filmproduzenten regisseure chef nico
hofmann danke ihnen danke herr weiler
bundestagsabgeordneter aus thüringen
wenn die kanzlerin angesichts des sturms
der da heruntergekommen ist auf die
schauspieler gesagt hätte ich lade sie
alle herzlich ein ins kanzleramt sie
wissen ich bin ganz anderer meinung aber
lasst uns friedlich lasst uns ordentlich
wie anständige menschen miteinander
diskutieren wäre es eine gute idee
gewesen
also wenn ich jetzt ganz so gewesen wäre
ich hätte sie alle eingeladen und hätte
ihn versucht klarzumachen was denn auch
die intention dabei ist das auf jeden
fall finde ich eine gute idee
aber ich bin kein kanzler frau
schließlich wäre das eine gute idee
gewesen ich habe manchmal den eindruck
wir führen doch alle im privaten genau
diese diskussion das ist ja auch
manchmal richtig hart da ist die frau
die ehefrau die eigene anderer meinung
als man selbst da sind verwandte die
anderer meinung sind freunde bekannte
nachbarn und so weiter und überall
müssen wir diesen streit aushalten wäre
das eine möglichkeit gewesen dann zu
sagen ich halte den auch auskommt sehr
wir diskutieren und streiten einfach mal
miteinander
also ich möchte jetzt da der kannst du
und keinen ratschlag geben aber ich kann
nur sagen dass wir das vor ort machen
also ich hab hier regelmäßig in schwerin
demonstrationen von den fitnessstudios
von den touristikern von den gastronomen
auch von eltern die dafür sind dass die
schulen geschlossen werden von eltern
die dafür sind dass sie wieder
aufgemacht werden also genau diese
kontroverse debatte natürlich auch
künstlerinnen und künstler für die wir
hier bei uns im bundesland mecklenburg
vorpommern haben wir ein extra
kulturform aufgelegt weil wir die
probleme sehen und finanzieren obwohl
die theater er zurzeit gar nicht spielen
können trotzdem alles weiter um so viel
wie möglich zu machen also ich will
damit sagen diese kontroverse debatte
gibt es doch vor ort also ich kann ihnen
jetzt gar nicht sagen wie viele demos
ich teilgenommen habe nicht als
initiatoren aber ich gehe dahin und das
sind kontroverse debatten und ich
verstehe auch pro und contra und ich
will auch noch mal sagen dass vielleicht
sollten wir wirklich unsere ganzen
sitzungen mittlerweile per livestream
übertragen obwohl sie ja auch gut
informiert sind
wir diskutieren auch in der politik auch
kontrovers und überlegen uns genau was
können wir verantworten was nicht da
machen das ja eines findigkeit wirksam
nachholbedarf
oder war das war das jetzt war das ernst
gemeint mit dem livestream weil
tatsächlich war das ja eine möglichkeit
gerade in diesen zeiten transparenz zu
schaffen also meinen sie das ernst haft
das findet ja schon statt zum beispiel
war jetzt eine debatte im bundestag und
bei uns ist das seit anfang an der
pandemie gang und gäbe dass alle
entscheidungen die wir treffen vorher im
parlament diskutiert werden ich als
ministerpräsident
dort vortragen was haben wir uns mit den
wissenschaftlern überlegt was haben wir
auch zum beispiel mit den sozialpartnern
beraten und dann wird es kontrovers
diskutiert das war ja nicht gemeint dass
man gemerkt dass man mir hier in der
bundestagsdebatte und landtags gab es ja
vorher auch im leistung dass mein
manchen sie ja gerade nicht aber die
entscheidungen die bisher hinter den
kulissen gefallen sind die zu übertragen
diesen vorschlag gab es ja schon auch
unter anderem vom csu-chef von
ministerpräsidenten in bayern markus
söder also bleibt es bei dem vorschlag
oder ist dass ernsthaft zu verfolgen
wegen mir kann zum beispiel die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz transparent
sein
aber nochmal die entscheidung wird dort
gar nicht gefällt sie wird im parlament
in mecklenburg vorpommern schon die
ganze zeit im parlament gefällt und
nicht irgendwo alleine im kabinett und
wir informieren immer transparent
hinterher und diese debatten im
parlament sind ja auch öffentlich und
nochmal ganz wichtig es gibt diese
vielen demos also nicht nur die
querdenker dem muss sondern wirklich die
demos von denen die tatsächlich
betroffen sind und da stellen wir uns
den diskussionen und ja ich erlebe dass
ich erlebe im bekanntenkreis soweit man
ja überhaupt dort jetzt diskutieren kann
man sieht sich ja gar nicht eigentlich
gar nicht mehr es geht nur am telefon
ich erlebe aber auch im natürlich ganz
normal in der bürgerschaft sozusagen
hier in mecklenburg vorpommern auf den
demonstrationen ich erlebe diese
kontroverse debatte die jetzt hier das
ganze land in atem hält und da müssen
wir uns dem aufstellen und ist auch
schwer
ich bin auch hin- und hergerissen ja ich
sehe das mit den kindern meine tochter
geht selber seit monaten nicht mehr in
die kita mittut selber im herzen weh
dass die kitas offene und betreuung sind
und sehe das auch bei meinem sohn und
habe natürlich viel kontakt zu vielen
familien und
sozusagen unter telefon und ich will
einfach nicht dass der eindruck stehen
bleibt dass wir nicht diese kontroverse
debatte steht und diese zerrissenheit
die hat jeder aber politik ist am ende
verantwortlich auch zu entscheiden
verstehe ich in der tat führen wir hier
regelmäßig diese debatten das ist glaube
ich tatsächlich nicht der punkt trotzdem
entsteht natürlich der eindruck dadurch
dass diese schauspieler so massiven
gegenwind bekommen so einen massiven
schritt storm und dann eben nicht das
video zurückziehen weil sie das gefühl
haben ha das war doch falsch was ich da
gesagt habe sondern weil sie angst haben
müssen so ist es ja im fall wäre besser
gewesen aber sie haben gerade die
unterschiedlichen meinungen auch in
ihrem umfeld angesprochen frau
schließlich kennen sie das bis ins
private ich habe gerade gesagt aus der
eigenen familie das natürlich ja der
riss geht da nicht durch aber schon eine
gewisse grenze durchläuft da weiß man
okay der sieht es ein bisschen anders
wenn ich den punkt an treppe dann haben
wir waren hier kennen sie so was aus dem
privaten also ich muss ehrlich sagen
dass ich privat zur zeit bis auf
telefonate kaum und meine familie sehr
natürlich mein mann und meine kinder
aber ansonsten sind wir sehr
eingeschränkt in den kontakten aber ich
habe es ja eben gesagt wenn meine
tochter mich morgens am frühstückstisch
fragt wann sie endlich in die kita kamen
sie vermisst ihre freunde dann blutet
mir genauso das herz das ist doch
logisch und auch wenn schule wieder
dicht gemacht wird und was was ich
glaube wichtig ist dass wir so weit es
geht wirklich sachlich in der diskussion
bleiben und ich will das sagen zu frau
becker natürlich geht das nicht
morddrohung kein niemals in unserer
demokratie kann hass gewalt oder
bedrohung 1 1 eine form der
auseinandersetzung zu sein
wir müssen jetzt wer ist unser feind das
virus das virus ist unser feind nicht
wir nicht wir bürgerinnen und bürger
sollten uns anfeinden federleicht
schlusswort unter diese debatte was
machen wir jetzt mit den videos die da
in ende vergangener woche eben
veröffentlicht wurden am donnerstag
nacht und die dann einen so gewaltigen
sturm ausgelöst haben einen shitstorm
ausgelöst haben bis hin zu morddrohungen
als dann am ende diese kritik die
intoniert wurde von den schauspielern
einfach ab ich glaube es wäre ein fehler
dass jetzt einfach rückgängig zu machen
und alles sondern tisch zu kehren und
was mir jetzt gerade auch in der debatte
aufgefallen ist es hat ja sehr viele von
rechts afd auf den plan gerufen
es sind aber nicht alle rechts oder afd
anhängig die tatsächlich und es sind
auch nicht alles corona gegner die
trotzdem die ganzen entscheidungen etwas
kritischer sehen also zum beispiel das
tübinger projekt da haben wir hier ist
so so viele zuschriften gekriegt sich
übrigens die ganze zeit noch wo die
leute einfach definitiv total frustriert
sind und sagen die politik hört uns gar
nicht zu die nimmt uns nicht ernst und
die nimmt uns jede hoffnung und kranken
tübinger projekttagen das kommt ja alles
aus meiner feder so zu sagen ja ich habe
ganz früh mit note strategie angefangen
ich habe mich ganz früh mit dem thema
beschäftigt sowie manuela schwesig von
ja auch gesagt hat dass sie das mit den
heimen übernommen hat ich habe mit den
heim angefangen habt dann im november
die ganzen leute in tübingen kostenlos
sich testen lassen können ja ich habe
ständig ständig an die politik
appelliert dass sie dieses konzept
übernehmen sollen ja um den menschen
auch zumindest die möglichkeit zu geben
dass wenn sie zur oma vor weihnachten
wollen oder in der vorweihnachtszeit
dass sie getestet werden können und zwar
kostenlos weil nicht jeder hat geld für
35 euro gab es hat niemand auf mich
gehört muss ich ganz klar sagen würden
dann bin ich extrem abgeprallt aber auch
der bund hat nicht auf mich gehört ich
habe dann spenden gesammelt wir haben
ganz viel wir haben kostenlos kostenlos
monate zwei monaten dagestanden und
getestet und getestet und getestet
umsonst alle ehrenamtlich ja und ganz
ehrlich es geht ja haben mir schon so
dass ich echt frustriert
das aus diesem projekt ist ja dann auch
dieses modellprojekt in tübingen
entstanden wir waren der erste landkreis
in baden-württemberg der unter 50 war
und auch dann unter 35 und wir haben
eine strategie ich hab' ich bin ja zum
boris palmer dann habe ihn gebeten als
20 mal überlegen ob wir das umsetzen
kann und ich will damit nur sagen an dem
an dem punkt merke ich das und das ist
schlecht das problem auch ja warum viele
sagen das interessiert die politik gar
nicht weil sie hätten zum beispiel bei
diesem projekt das so immer schick
begleitet ist wo auch die wissenschaft
gesagt hat lasst es wir können es
vertreten und da hat man dann einfach
das gefühl es interessiert nicht man
macht einfach zu unfertig und alles
andere wird nicht akzeptiert und ich
glaube genau das führt dann auch leute
die ein ich gar keine cola gegner sind
aber dies zumindest gewisse zweifel
haben und erleben sie gerade auch
aufgrund der neuen gesetzgebung vor
federle dass sie ihr modellprojekt
erstmal wieder beerdigen müssen
zumindest vorläufig dort in tübingen es
hat auswirkungen auf ganz viele
landkreise auf ganz viele regionen
aktuell der neue sogenannte bundes lockt
da eine andere sagen bundes notbremse
und ich will ihnen noch ein mann
vorstellen der von uns allen am aller
aller längsten im lock down ist das ist
nämlich michael koller der
stellvertretende landrat aus dem
berchtesgadener land berichtet baden
schwer getroffen in sachen lockdown
schönen guten abend herr koller
sie sind nämlich mittlerweile ich hoffe
ich habe richtig gerechnet 188 tage im
lockdown nämlich seit dem 20
oktober was genau steht bei ihnen still
oder umgekehrt vielleicht leichter
gefragt was was läuft überhaupt noch bei
ihnen also die plötzlich in der runde
grüßen als im berchtesgadener land
natürlich nicht nachgezählt wie viel
tage hier tatsächlich im lok darm sind
aber es ist natürlich schon gefühlt eine
ewigkeit und es steht natürlich in einer
region die vom tourismus geprägt ist die
hotellerie die casterin und
ganze touristische branche seit mitte
oktober still und das ist für viele
natürlich existenzbedrohend ist die
situation hier vor angespannt wir haben
sorge und haben gott sei dank das
produzierende gewerbe die branche
deklariert sich doch einiges wieder eine
ganz realistische sparte ist hier ein
großes wehrmacht amoralisch mental noch
mit bei ihnen im berchtesgadener land
nach so vielen tagen
gott sei dank muss nun wirklich ein lob
an die bevölkerung berichten dass viele
sich als diszipliniert verhalten zu
liszt ressourcen so gut wie möglich
einen familiären kreis zu regeln aber
sie ist natürlich die sorge groß besteht
die perspektive wie geht es weiter wir
haben keine aussichten waren lockerungen
teams öffnungs strategie wann können
gäste beherbergt werden
für viele ist es ein wichtiges standbein
die beherbergung wir haben hier mit den
fünf gemeinden des südens 2000 betriebe
die beherbergung anbieten
die ohne unterstützung in den letzten
monaten auskommen müssen
das macht für viele sehr schwierig und
hier ist einfach die politik gefordert
perspektiven zu bieten einfach ein
auszug zuständig unserer hinter geben
ich erinnere mich noch wie das war als
sie im oktober eine locker und gegen da
hieß es ja da explodieren gerade die
zahlen da unten im berchtesgadener land
in diesem kessel sozusagen und jetzt
machen wir mal schnell zu und zwar
radikal zu damit war dann auch bald
wieder aufmachen können all das es nicht
eingetreten sind sie jetzt
zuversichtlich dass mit der neuen
gesetzgebung dass das gelingt eben
dadurch bundesweit die bälle zu brechen
so dass es auch bei ihnen wieder
normales leben geben kann keine hoffnung
auf diese bundesgesetzgebung ehrlich
gesagt wir werden wirklich lösungen für
vor ort und aus der region heraus lieber
gewesen und wichtiger gewesen denkt
großes stück wird demokratie ist der
föderalismus und wir können hier
verordnet haben es entscheidend dass wir
uns erst wir haben uns noch im oktober
wirklich gut aufgestellt strategien
entwickelt gottseidank läuft die
impfstrategie bislich besser als noch
vor einigen wochen und es gibt hier ein
interessantes
zusammen mit der tu münchen ist abwasser
monitoring- wo man sehr früh mehr
so bildet sich ein cluster wo kommen wir
unfallzahlen er damit wir sofort vom
gesundheitsamt aus einschreiten kann
geraten kann testen kann es ihr denkmal
wir seien hier vor ort sehr gut
aufgestellt mittlerweile und es erfolgte
nix wenn man von flensburg bis
berchtesgaden hier einheitlich einfach
drüber wird regionen zu unterschiedlich
und ich denke in der region hat ganz
spezifisch ihre schwerpunkte und danach
ihr gezielt maßnahmen er könne sich
berchtesgadener land das es von ihnen
maximale weit entfernt jetzt gibt es
aber einheitliche regelungen zur
ausgangssperren schaffen dies dass mit
blick von ihnen aus dem norden ganz in
den süden dass es auch da unten wieder
gut wird dass die irgendwann raus kommen
mit diesen ausgangssperren die jetzt
bundesweit beschlossen wurden
einheitlich bei bestimmten werten
also bei der ausgangs beschränkung finde
ich es richtig dass die bundesweit
einheitlich ist weil ein solcher
grundrechtseingriff gehört auch in einem
bundesgesetz
ich glaube aber nicht dass dieses
bundesgesetz so wie es jetzt beschlossen
worden ist wirklich helfen wird es hat
nämlich folgenden grund es gibt eine es
droht eine pendelbewegung wenn jetzt ein
landkreis drei tage über 100 kommt 101
dann wird die ausgangs beschränkung
gemacht dann gibt es schließung und wenn
dann dieser landkreis fünf tage unter
100 ist vielleicht 98 97 dann wird
wieder aufgemacht und wir alle wissen
dass diese starren instanzen nicht
alleine das richtige instrument sind und
dann wird es so eine pendelbewegung
geben auf zu aufzug und das wird die
menschen mürbe machen deswegen sehe ich
dieses gesetz so wie es angelegt ist
sozusagen kritisch und was wichtig ist
dass die regionen vor ort auch selber
steuern können müssen was aber eben ein
echtes ganz deutlich wurde ist dass wir
in der wirtschaft auch eine spaltung
haben große teile der wirtschaft
arbeiten in der korona pandemie wie
bisher und machen sogar noch mehr
umsätze der lebensmittelbereich auch die
baubranche der geht es gut und andere
teile der wirtschaft ein kleinerer teil
aber auch ein wichtiger die vor allem
der tourismus die gastronomie die hotels
aber auch die kultur und die
veranstaltungsbranche und der
einzelhandel der verein tourismus hängt
der macht sowie auch fitnessstudios
kosmetikstudios seit einem halben jahr
ist der sozusagen die börse sind zwei
klassen gesellschaft das sagt
zweiklassengesellschaft genau das ist
ein großes problem und da kommt jetzt
auch ein wahnsinniger frust weil zu
recht ein gastronom hat mich zum
beispiel angesprochen letzten also vor
schwierig ich darf hier nichts und
gegenüber ist eine baustelle da geht
alles und das geht für uns nicht seit
monaten und deswegen finde ich müsste
die bundesregierung diesen branchen
insbesondere eben auch der
tourismusbranche die hier ein
sonderopfer bringen aus meiner sicht
auch eine sonder wirtschaftshilfe geben
dann wäre auch würden wir auch wieder
viel druck rausnehmen dann sind wir mal
ehrlich gerade ist ihr geld
ich will dass nur ganz kurz übersetzten
frau schwesig sonderwirtschaftszone
bedeuten ja noch mal mehr geld aber die
wollen ja arbeiten die wollen ja
eigentlich also so ist zumindest mein
eindruck die wollen nicht dass das hotel
geschlossen bleibt und die gastronomie
beschlossen geschlossen bleibt natürlich
hilft es ein bisschen mehr geld zu
bekommen aber die wollen ja aufmachen
wollen ja eine perspektive haben die
wollen nicht zu hause sitzen
da haben sie völlig recht das ist ja
noch der zweite druck der dazu kommt in
diesen branchen dass einer die
existenzsorgen und das war es jetzt
schon so lange gibt und dass andere
natürlich auch dass sie nicht das machen
können was ihr leben bestimmt womit sie
auch erfolgreich sind
aber wenn wir auf die hohen zahlen schon
in vielen regionen wissen wir dass wir
nicht zum jetzt im mai den tourismus
öffnen können um mal bei der branche zu
bleiben und so geht's ja auch der kultur
und der veranstaltungsbranche und da
wäre ich dafür dass wir noch einmal das
wiederholen was wir schon im november
und dezember gemacht haben
dort waren die wirtschaftshilfen am
umsatz gekoppelt und das war wesentlich
besser für diese branche als jetzt die
überbrückungshilfe 3 und ich finde schon
dass wir in deutschland gerade in denen
branchen die eben diesen sonne auch
verbringen wo sie sehen bei anderen geht
alles so weiter dass wir da noch mal ein
stück mehr helfen müssen wir als land
haben dafür ein extra
wirtschaftsprogramm aber ist ja völlig
klar dass ein einzelnes land ist auch
nicht alleine ausgleichen wenn man
riesenpaket was da geschnürt würde von
denen die im moment steuern zahlen und
eben arbeiten aber sie sagen das ist
eine zweiklassengesellschaft das müssen
wir ein bisschen aufheben jetzt endlich
wieder herr koller ich wollte noch mal
bei dem stichwort ausgangssperren
bleiben wie wird das bei ihnen im
landkreis eigentlich kontrolliert ja das
ist natürlich schwierig so was zu
kontrollieren und ich sag mal die
ausgangssperre
wenn es immer von verschärfungen jetzt
die rede ist hier vor ort hieß es dort
wir haben die verschärfte variante
seit aber immer wieder mit unterbrechung
wenn wir die inzidenz wert unter 100
schaffen aber es ist auch unterschied ob
die ausgangssperre sollte man den
wintermonaten muss um 17 uhr dunkel wird
einhalten sondern wurde jetzt im
frühjahr wo eigentlich die vegetation
wieder anfängt alles zu blühen dass es
länger hell ist
da kann ich natürlich schlecht davon
sprechen dass nur 21 uhr daheim sein
soll und keine messe ausgeben möchte
darauf eingehen was die verschließung
sagte dass wir hier ganz
unterschiedliche voraussetzungen haben
die baubranche die gastronomie das zieht
sich durch wenn jetzt bei uns in der
region shy es gibt große discounter die
alles anbieten können ohne großen test
vorher ohne große strategie an ihrem
großen discountern kleidung schuhe
elektrogeräte spielsachen kaufen und
hier in unseren orten seien die
einzelhandelsgeschäfte alle geschlossen
ist nicht nur die gastronomie
eingeschränkt sondern auch der ganze
einzelhandel vor ort liegt hier braucht
und diese ungleichbehandlung ist meines
erachtens nicht mit unterstützung der
mit mördern und geld dann zu leben
sondern wir müssen arbeiten dürfen wir
müssen konsumieren dürfen und die
branchen haben sie wirklich durchgehend
gute konzepte überlegt wenn ich halt
schade dass wenn discounter die blumen
angeliefert werden in großen regalen und
gärten nicht mehr anders schauen wie er
sich über das kühling bringt ob er mit
tests und welchen strategien auch immer
öffnen darf dann ist es ungleich und
dieses gemüses förderung mit zahlen wird
muss ja irgendwo erarbeitet werden das
nehmen wir mit aus der runde herr koller
an frau schwesig und dann die
bundesregierung dass diese
ungerechtigkeiten jetzt endlich beendet
werden müssen derweil noch mal zu den
kontrollen der ausgangssperren weil das
ja ganz viele menschen in diesen stunden
zum ersten mal erleben oder eben von
zuhause gespannt sind wird man sich da
wirklich dran halten
wie wird das bei ihnen kontrolliert
haben sie da schon eindruck sind da auch
im vielleicht ein bisschen ruhe ihren
saalfeld in thüringen ist da plötzlich
polizei auf den straßen vermehrt abends
fährt daraus kontrolliert die leute
fragt sie was sie hier noch draußen
machen also bei den personalstand in die
polizeiakten thüringen ist die polizei
gar nicht in der lage das zu
kontrollieren
die ganzen kleinen
wir sind sehr kleinteilig viele kleine
dörfer also wie gesagt ich schaffe das
gar nicht und wenn ich mich mit den
menschen unterhalten
die verstehen das auch nicht die
verstehen nicht warum sie sich nicht
gesellschaft nicht treffen können zum
beispiel in einem außenbereich mit vier
leuten an einem tisch in der
außengastronomie
das sind keine treiber der pandemie und
trotzdem dürfen sie es nicht und dann
wieder koller schon sagte wird von
norden bis süden alles gleich behandelt
vor allen dingen auch die städte werden
gleich behandelt mit den dörfern das
passt alles nicht zusammen und deshalb
habe ich auch gegen dieses gesetz
gestimmt das ist nicht richtig was da
passiert und das passiert auch jetzt
genau das hat sich die bundeskanzlerin
merkel am dienstag in der fraktion
vorausgesagt habe ihn am dienstag vor
einer woche und habe gesagt müssen sie
frau merkel was passieren wird die
ministerpräsidenten werden als erstes
wenn wenn die ausgangssperre kommt den
bund kritisieren und sagen
die maßnahmen die jetzt gemacht sind
sind falsch das habe ich von herrn
ramelow gehört dass ihr euch jetzt
wieder von frau schwesig ich bin kein
hellseher aber ich glaube dafür muss man
auch kein hellseher sein um das dann zu
sehen also nochmal wir brauchen mehr
freiheit wir müssen den menschen wieder
wieder hoffnung geben und das passiert
im moment nicht nur zu machen zu machen
zu machen frau schwesig noch mal ganz
kurz zu der praxis zurück haben sie den
eindruck schon wie viele polizisten bei
ihnen im land das kontrollieren werden
also die
abendliche nächtlichen ausgangssperren
und dann auch die einreiseverbote an den
autobahnen wo sie herausfischen
also wir haben ja schon seit sehr langem
ausgangs beschränkungen in den
landkreisen und oder auch hier in meiner
eigenen heimatstadt schwerin die stärker
betroffen sind und deshalb wir haben
damit gute erfahrungen gemacht also im
großen und ganzen halten die leute sich
dran wir hatten eine strengere ausgangs
beschränkung sogar schon ab 21 uhr und
jetzt ist eigentlich die ausgangs
beschränkung durch die bundesregierung
sogar lockerer geworden kann man sagen
auch mit der spaziergang variante wir
machen auch bei und rollen an den
landesgrenzen weil wir viele haben die
natürlich dann doch gerne über ostern
ins land kommen was wir auch verstehen
und wir versuchen vor allem die leute
darauf hinzuweisen wie die regeln sind
und die rückmeldung von der polizei ist
das sich im großen und ganzen alle daran
halten und es würde ich gerne zum
schluss auch sagen wollen bei aller
diskussion
wir kommen nur durch die pandemie wenn
alle bürgerinnen und bürger mitmachen
und ich bin wirklich beeindruckt ein
problem die es auch gibt vor ort und
auch denen die damals sich nicht also
auch denen die dagegen sind
der ganz grosse teil hält sich dran und
sonst würden wir auch gar nicht durch
die pandemie kommen stellt ihn ein mann
vor der hat stephan goericke der wohnt
in potsdam
und wenn er dort los fährt dann ist sein
ziel guten abend herr göricke ganz oft
rügen nämlich putbus dort manuela
schwesig kennt den ort gut dann fährt er
los mit seinem auto in putbus mai in
potsdam meistens mit der familie an bord
und dann geht es die navi lang braucht
man vielleicht drei stunden würde ich
sagen wenn ein bisschen verkehr ist da
ganz oben drauf in den norden und dort
fährt er so oft hin weil er einen
zweitwohnsitz dort hat aber geht im
moment nicht einreiseverbote nach
mecklenburg vorpommern wenn das nicht
der hauptwohnsitz ist jetzt weiß ich
aber herr göricke sie sind im moment
trotzdem dort oben warum er zum einen
weil es so schön ist aber zum anderen
weil ich mich eigentlich schon seit
mitte dezember hier aufhalte mit meiner
familie mit drei wochen unterbrechung wo
wir unsere kinder in den
präsenzunterricht potsdam bringen
mussten ansonsten machen wir home office
homeschooling hier vor ort und wir sind
ununterbrochen seit dem 23
märz eigentlich hier
wir haben allerdings die aufforderung
bekommen durch die landesregierung und
durch frau schwesig jetzt sozusagen zu
packen und werden sozusagen zu
unerwünschten personen erklärt und wir
müssen unseren zweitwohnsitz der also
seit dezember unser lebensmittelpunkt
ist jetzt verlassen
das finde ich frau schwesig eben bei
allem was sie sagen ich bin nicht durch
und ich bin auch nicht frustriert ich
habe alles mitgemacht als unternehmer
tests gekauft als es keine gab was
gekauft kostenlos zur verfügung gestellt
gespendet künstler unterstützt
wir haben uns hierher begeben weil wir
sagen wir wollen wenig kontakt wir
wollen er sozusagen dahin wo man wenig
leute trifft wo die kinder das auch
aushalten und jetzt zwingen sie mich im
prinzip zu packen und in einen höheren
instanz wert zu fahren also sozusagen
meine kinder in dieser gefährdung
auszusetzen denn der inzidenz wert in
potsdam ist viel höher als hier derzeit
aber wenn ich sozusagen das befolgen
würde was der landtag beschlossen hat
auf ihre vorlage hin
dann ist es das gegenteil von dem was
das gesetz soll nämlich die gesundheit
zu schützen und das kann ich nicht
akzeptieren
und schließlich würden sie sagen
luxusproblem das trifft jetzt ein paar
soll zurückfahren nach potsdam oder wenn
sie sagen da in solchen fällen wäre
schon vernünftig wenn er einfach da
bleiben könnte in putbus auf rügen mit
seiner familie
ich möchte einmal erläutern warum wir
uns dazu entschieden haben
wir haben im land sehr früh hier die
notbremse gezogen und sind sehr streng
ich kann diese einzelsitze diesen einzel
blick des bürgers kann ich verstehen
aber die gesamtsituation des landes ist
so dass unser gesundheitssystem
ausgerichtet ist auf die bevölkerung
hier in mecklenburg vorpommern wir haben
alarmsignal aus unserem gesundheitswesen
bekommen dass die belastung sehr stark
ist ich möchte es nicht ausreizen ich
möchte nicht dass wir ans limit gehen
und es übertreiben und wir haben das
gesundheitswesen für die bevölkerung
hier und wir haben ja nicht nur ein
zweitwohnungsbesitzer sondern wir haben
60.000 zweitwohnungsbesitzer und
besitzer wir haben diese regel schon mal
in der ersten welle gehabt und ich kenne
welche die dafür verständnis haben ich
kenne welche die kein verständnis haben
das ist jetzt für einige wochen ich
denke das ist vertretbar
auch gegenüber den kindern die ihm gar
nicht in kita und schule können
gegenüber denjenigen die seit monaten
nicht arbeiten alle neben
einschränkungen hin und deswegen denke
ich es ist vertretbar und das gericht
hat ja gerade diese regel überprüft und
hat uns an der stelle auch recht gegeben
also nochmal ja sagt ja aus seiner
individuellen sicht frau schwesig für
ihn ist halt quatsch weil in potsdam die
inzidenz viel höher ist jetzt ist das
schon so lange mit seinen kindern dort
oben und sagt halt mensch wir sind im
wesentlichen in der wohnung treffen
wenig menschen ich bleib halt einfach
hier würden sie dem zustimmen können sie
dessen individuelle sicht sehen und was
vor allen dingen machen sie wenn er da
blatt ohren sind raus oder lassen ihn
herausholen
ich gehe davon aus dass der bürger sich
fair verhält gegenüber allen bürgerinnen
und bürgern in unserem land wir haben
diese regeln alle menschen in unserem
land haben einschränkungen von den
kleinsten die ihm zurzeit nicht in die
kita gehen können oder schule ist über
viele die zurzeit nicht arbeiten dürfen
viele familien die in
der hängenden wohnverhältnissen sind und
wenig spielraum haben und ich denke wir
haben alle in dieser zeit haben viele
bürger einschränkungen zu machen und ich
respektiere diese kritik aber wir haben
uns so entschieden wir haben mit den
strengen regeln in der ersten welle gute
erfahrungen gemacht wissen sie wenn man
jeden einzelfall sieht dann kann jeder
sagen
in meinem geschäft passiert nichts in
bei mir im theater passiert nichts ich
als familie sie treffe keinen da
passiert auch nichts jeder für sich
individuell hat sicherlich gute gründe
aber wir haben eine pandemie und wir
haben eine gesamtsituation die wir
schauen müssen und jetzt müssen alle
solidarisch sein und ich denke die
familie der familie ist das für einige
wochen zu zumuten und ich hoffe sehr
dass unser land wieder wir sind ja zum
glück in den infektionszahlen auch noch
unter bundesdurchschnitt
aber wenn jetzt jeder sagt ja dann
kommen wir nach mecklenburg vorpommern
da ist es besser als woanders
dann wird es schwierig und nochmal
unsere hauptpunkt ist die belastung des
gesundheitssystems und für mich ist es
wichtig es ist jetzt schon sehr
belastend für die pfleger und für die
ärzte ich habe mit vielen gesprochen und
ich will hier einmal was sagen ich
selber hatte das große glück meine
krebstherapie zu überleben weil menschen
da waren und medizin und ist nicht knapp
wurde und ich möchte dass das auch für
alle anderen bürgerinnen und bürger
weiter so möglich ist und das ist das
was für mich sozusagen der hauptgrund
ist dass wir viele einschränkungen
vertreten müssen dass es den einzelnen
hart trifft das weiß ich und insofern
respektiere ich auch diese kritik aber
bitte dass alle an einem strang ziehen
das ist ein hoch emotionaler appell von
ihnen frau schwesig ein sehr
persönlicher appell auch an herrn gary
kann sie packen sie die koffer und
fahren sie erst recht nach diesem appell
zurück persönlichen verständnis und
sympathie für vor schwierig die ja
durchaus habe trifft zu den falschen wie
sind wir belasten das system hier
überhaupt nicht und ihr eigener
bürgerbeauftragter frau schwierig das
wissen sie ja kritisiert ja diese
regelung weil sie eben
im verwaltungshandeln einzelfälle
berücksichtigen müssen es geht nicht
darum dass wir meine blumen vertrocknen
so wird ja einmal getan von der politik
sondern es geht darum dass sie meine
grundrechte eingreifen
es ist auch kein privileg was ich
einfordere oder weil sie an die fans
appellieren sie müssen begründen warum
sie bestimmen wollen wo mein wohnsitz
ist so ist die rechtslage in deutschland
das sind grundrechte die müssen
begründet werden wenn sie mitnehmen und
nicht wieder geben
und das erwarte ich und anders als sie
annehmen ist der rechtsweg lange nicht
ausgeschöpft
ich verhalte mich fair gegenüber jedem
ich helfe wo ich kann als unternehmer
wie auch als privatperson und förderer
ich bin selbst ford ist der deutsche
parkinson hilfe frau schwesig ich nur
dass sie willkürlich eingreifen in die
grundrechte und hier sozusagen es muss
angemessen und erforderlich sein und ihr
bürgerbeauftragten sagt das ist es eben
nicht ganz kurzen sie ziehen das durch
und werden auch klagen
ich klage ich habe 12 den rechtsschutz
beantragt da sind die finalen
entscheidung noch nicht getroffen
und sollte das sozusagen nicht über den
14 rechtsschutz gehen werde ich auch
versuchen meine verfassung verbrieften
rechte durchzusetzen dann gehen für
dieses gespräch mörike sie haben gerade
ein thema schon angesprochen und das war
das immer mehr freiheiten endlich die
freiheiten zurück für all die die
geimpft sind da hat am wochenende
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
ganz interessiert
interessante dinge gesagt er hat nämlich
jetzt gesagt nach dem abarbeiten von
bereits vereinbarten impftermin hier
seine zitate in der heutigen bild am
sonntag sollten alle impfstoffe für
jeden komplett freigegeben werden das
sollte man am besten noch im mai das
sollte am besten noch im mai verfolgen
also die völlige freigabe von impftermin
frau schwesig
ist das der richtige weg und wann können
wir damit bundesweit rechnen
genau darüber müssen wir morgen mit der
bundesregierung sprechen ich finde es
grundsätzlich gut wenn wir die
prioritäten weiter öffnen um einfach
auch organisatorisch vor ort mit dem
impfen gut voran zu kommen aber wenn
damit verbunden
dass jeder bürger und jede bürgerin
jetzt denkt sie kriegt einen impftermin
ist das nur zu schaffen wenn wir
genügend impfstoff haben und wir haben
wir bekommen zwar jede woche jetzt ein
bisschen mehr impfstoff aber es reicht
eben nicht um jeder beheben bürger und
jede bürgerin ein impfangebot zu machen
und davon ist das dann abhängig herr
söder hat ja aus solidarischen gründen
weil es vor ort große probleme gibt mehr
impfstoff bekommen aber wir brauchen
jetzt alle bundesländer mehr impfstoff
um genau diesen schritt zu gehen aber
soll das morgen beschlossen werden
erstmal das was herr söder gerade ja wie
ich hier gerade zitiert hat also die
aufgabe der impf priorisierung
ich erwarte von der bundesregierung
morgen dass sie erstens uns genau
vorstellt wie viele impfdosen kommen und
zu welchem zeitpunkt man dann diese ins
priorisierung aufgeben kann weil dafür
brauchen wissen sie brauchen sie einfach
viel impfstoff in der sache bin ich auch
dafür es wäre wesentlich unkomplizierter
und der zweite punkt ist dass wir auch
dann zum beispiel viel mehr mobile
einsatzteams der bundeswehr einsetzen
könnten wir haben es hier bei uns
ausprobiert wir sind ja ein flächenland
das ist noch mal anders als im
stadtstaat und da müssen sie in die
dörfer reihen da müssen sie in die
kleinen orte rein mit den ins bussen
wir mussten das projekt jetzt kurz
wieder einstellen weil inter impfstoff
dafür fehlt herr koller letzte frage an
sie wie groß ist der druck von denen im
berchtesgadener land die schon geimpft
sind dass sie wieder raus können wieder
alles machen können was sie wollen wie
erleben sie diesen druck dort den druck
als zu groß
wichtiger ist dass man sie wirklich und
es ist ihr im bett ist gerade auch schon
große und der einfach verlangt wird dass
wir die gastronomie die ganzen
touristische branche mit perspektive
ausstattungen eröffnen können ja nicht
dass einzelne personen ihr eigenes
interesse in den vordergrund stellen und
immer story zu großes lob aussprechen
ist dass er so egal ist natürlich
spricht man davon dass einfach für
geimpfte der durchaus forderungen kommen
sollen
es merkt ja schon jetzt bei dem schönen
wetter ist einfach ganz viele leute
unterwegs die aus anderen landkreisen
hier natürlich einen
schluss tage erleben wollen da ist
natürlich froh wenn die kampagne
funktioniert und wenn danach die
institute aus weitere möglichkeiten
bestehen
vielen dank an sie herr koller ich weiß
sie müssen weg deswegen hier schon mal
die vorzeitige verabschiedung an sie
aber lassen wir uns bleiben in der runde
bei dem thema freiheit für geimpfte der
druck wird da schon immer größer weil
natürlich immer mehr menschen in
deutschland geimpft sind federle werden
sie dafür sofort alle grundrechte aller
einschränkungen zu streichen alle
grundrechte zurückzugeben für all die
die geimpft sind
ich wäre dafür dass geimpfte man muss
darüber entsprechend dass geimpfte eben
einen vorteil bekommen und nicht mehr so
behandelt haben es macht auch keinen
sinn immer halt dort zahlen die ganzen
älteren menschen die geimpft worden sind
ständig durch zu testen
aber was ich trotzdem immer noch
bedenken möchte und das ist wirklich
jetzt überhaupt nicht rausgekommen
wir haben es auch weiterhin mit neue
mutation zu tun und die indische
variante sind wir uns im moment noch
nicht sicher ob dämmstoff war wirklich
so greift das heißt wir brauchen
weiterhin ganz dringend ein alarmsystem
und ich finde es ganz schwierig wenn
jetzt die politik sich nur quasi auf das
impfen verlässt weil sowie frau
schließlich von gesagt hat wir müssen da
halt jetzt noch einmal durch das haben
die bürger jetzt schon so oft gehört
dass genau dieser satz fehlen inzwischen
wirklich richtig probleme macht und ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt weiter ein
konzept entwickeln was wir tun wenn
beispielsweise das mit der impfung nicht
so hundertprozentig funktioniert wie wir
uns das vorstellen
um solche situationen zu verhindern weil
eins kann ich ihnen sagen freitag
letzte woche hat ein partner bei uns
sagen müssen die schulen machen jetzt
dicht die waren ja bei uns offen weil
wir modellprojekt waren die schüler an
geweint den sind wirklich die tränen
runtergelaufen und das find ich das ist
eine situation dass kamen meine kurze
zeit machen
können sie aber nicht über ein jahr oder
noch länger machen und wir haben da war
ziemlich viel aufzuarbeiten in nächster
zeit überhaupt in den nächsten jahren
und ich glaube das ist wirklich ein ganz
wichtiger punkt und dann möchte ich
bitte an sie auch frau schwesig
weitergeben
denken sie daran dass wir ein
alarmsystem entwickeln und nicht einfach
sagen impfen ist alles und das war's
dann
wir müssen die ganze welt impfen um
einigermaßen sicher zu sein und das wird
so schnell nicht funktionieren und dann
kommt wieder das problem mit den neu
mutation und das ist einfach gefährlich
ich bitte sie dringend und deswegen war
mir tübing so wichtig nicht falls jetzt
mein projekt ist darum geht es gar nicht
aber es war eine hoffnung für die leute
und es wäre ein gutes projekt gewesen zu
sehen ob es in so einer krise bestand
hat und ob das stimmt was die
wissenschaftler sagen
dadurch dass es jetzt geklappt ist haben
wir die chance dich und das finde ich
schade
frau schwesig zudem meine frage oben
drauf was ist mit den freiheiten für
geimpfte ihre minister ihre ministerin
christine lambrecht justizministerin im
bund die hat von einem gebot der
verfassung gesprochen dass eben
diejenigen die geimpft sind auch
wirklich die grundrechte
schnellstmöglich wieder zurückbekommen
ein gebot der verfassung würde ja
bedeuten wer geimpft ist der braucht die
grundrechte vollständig sofort zurück
der wartet jetzt nicht wie harald meyer
sagt noch ein bisschen juni bis sie
bereit sind darüber zu reden und dann
vielleicht irgendwann sondern der
bekommt die grundrechte zurück ich bin
bei dem thema zurückhaltend weil ich
finde zwei dinge geklärt werden müssen
ist wirklich sichergestellt dass dann
auch mit blick auf neue mutationen
sozusagen keine gefahr mehr besteht auch
für die geimpften und zweitens viel
wichtiger wenn wir hier weitere wieder
rechte
ermöglichen muss die bundesregierung mit
mehr impfstoff auch sicherstellen dass
wir den bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses
angebot machen können
dann schauen sie es ist ja nur ein
kleiner teil bisher zweimal geimpft es
ist ja ganz wichtig dass die bürgerinnen
und bürger die auf die impfung warten
und dann auch dieses angebot bekommen
diese beiden sachen müssen geklärt sein
schlussrunde machen wir auch mit stefan
wolf noch dem gesamtmetall präsidenten
den ich herzlich begrüße schönen guten
abend herr wolf wir sind mitten immer
der in der debatte rund ums impfen sie
samen unserer diskussion verfolgt wie
ist denn überhaupt die impfbereitschaft
aktuell einzuschätzen ich höre dass aus
einigen branchen weiß es aus dem
persönlichen umfeld dass es sehr viel
skepsis gibt aber höre dass eben
beispielsweise auch aus schulen von
lehrern von erziehern dass da jetzt
nicht gerade enthusiastisch ausgebrochen
ist bei vielen wie erleben sie das in
ihrer branche braucht möglicherweise
anreize um die menschen zum impfen zu
bringen also das sehe ich ehrlich gesagt
völlig anders wir haben eine extrem hohe
bereitschaft extrem hohe nachfrage zum
impfen und wir müssen endlich impfstoff
in unsere betriebe bekommen weil wenn
unsere betriebsärzte der anfangen zu
impfen dann haben wir eine relativ
schnelle durchdringung wenn sie alleine
die metall elektro industrie in
deutschland nehmen wir haben
beschäftigte 3,9 millionen menschen in
unseren betrieben und wir können dinge
glaube ich gut organisieren in unserer
industrie und wir würden es gut
organisieren wir haben auch schon
vorkehrungen getroffen wir könnten
einsteigen was fehlt ist der impfstoff
frau schwesig können sie da hoffnung
machen denn das ist ja tatsächlich
logisch das ist auch etwas was wir hier
sehen dass die betriebe bereit sind zu
impfen in dem moment wo der impfstoff da
ist das heißt erzielen sie dann morgen
durchbruch dass die betriebsärzte den
stoff bekommen
ich würde mich darüber sehr freuen weil
wir die betriebsärzte brauchen auch wir
haben zum beispiel hier mit der
lebensmittelindustrie weil wir hier ein
großes cluster haben in mecklenburg
vorpommern schon ein kleines im zentrum
aufgebaut und die betriebsärzte können
wir könnten mit der bundeswehr mobile in
busse einsetzen für die fläche es gibt
so viel im nahen strand hinten in museen
würden am strand gerne machen in flammen
stand ja das klingt gut aber mir würde
für mich war heute kämpfen ohne strand
dabei ist klingt natürlich noch nette
aber sie haben gerade noch einige zeit
einfach nicht sagen
es gibt so viele kapazitäten die wir
noch haben beim impfen die brachen durch
für den impfstoff
das muss die bundesregierung morgen
sagen ob wirklich richtig viel mehr
kommt denn zurzeit sind die impfzentren
nicht ausgelastet auch die ärzte können
noch viel mehr impfen und wir brauchen
natürlich wenn wir die betriebsärzte
jetzt die betriebe mit an bord nehmen wo
ich sehr für bin weil sie da ja dann
auch viel strecke machen und kurzer zeit
wenn ich das mal so sagen darf dann
brauchen sie aber auf den impfstoff
dafür aber das wollte ich noch ganz kurz
hören hat sein sich auch noch mehr
impfstoff kommen genau darauf wollte ich
hinaus verzeihen sie genau darauf wollte
hinaus also was erwarten sie konkret von
der bundesregierung weil sie haben
gerade so höflich gesagt habe würde ich
mich freuen wenn beispielsweise herr
wolf bei gesamtmetall jetzt endlich für
seine betriebsärzte den impfstoff
bekommen da würde ich mich darüber
freuen aber vielleicht haben sie ein
bisschen härter erwartungen an die
regierung
da ich aber meine forderung ist bekannt
dass wir mehr impfstoff brauchen und wir
sind wenn man sich jetzt die
lieferzahlen anguckt auch bis ende juni
es sind das noch so wird es zwar stück
für stück mehr was sind nicht die großen
massen und wir wollen von der
bundesregierung morgen wissen wie es
auch vielleicht mit weiteren impfstoffen
aussieht ob weitere optionen gezogen
werden wie zum beispiel auch bei sputnik
v oder anderen impfstoffen
wir haben noch viele kapazitäten aber
die können wir erst hochfahren nicht
wirklich mehr impfstoff wenn sie das
hören er wolfern gehen sie davon aus
dass bei jedem flächendeckend in den
betrieben geimpft werden kann durch die
betriebsärzte also ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir im mai beginnen können
allein mir fehlt der glaube weil da eben
von der bundesregierung extrem viele
fehler gemacht worden sind
man hat auch versucht
mit der endlosen diskussion um die
testpflicht bei unternehmen versuch
davon abzulenken dass man sich nicht um
dem impfstoff gekümmert hat ich bin ganz
bei frau federle wir brauchen eine
doppelstrategie wir müssen impfen und
wir müssen testen denn wir werden mit
diesem virus leben müssen in der zukunft
das wird nicht plötzlich verschwinden in
der zweiten jahreshälfte sondern es wird
weiter unser leben begleiten und wir
müssen strategien finden auch in unseren
betrieben wo wir impfen und testen
parallel um die menschen abzusichern
denn wir brauchen die menschen in
unseren betrieben wenn die menschen
unseren betrieben nicht arbeiten dann
fehlt uns wohlstand in deutschland dann
gehen arbeitsplätze kaputt und das
wollen wir ja sicherlich alle nicht
deswegen doppelstrategie
und es wäre schön frau schwesig wenn sie
morgen vielleicht darauf drängen dass
sie bereits impfstoff vorhanden ist und
dann muss die bundesregierung eben sich
mal beine machen und schauen wo sie den
impfstoff er bekommt sie versprechen uns
nämlich an so habe ich sie verstanden
frau schwesig dass sie darauf drängen es
liegt nicht alleine oder nicht
wesentlich in ihrer hand aber so habe
ich sie gerade schon verstanden noch ein
letztes wort herr wolf wo sehen sie in
dieser jetzt schon so lange corona krise
den größten fehler der regierung
ich glaube man hat erstens viel zu spät
angefangen sich im stoff zu sichern man
hat damit gehadert man hat lange
gewartet hat die dinge er auch über die
eu laufen lassen was sicherlich ein
fehler war wir hätten vielleicht auch
eine deutsche strategie fahren sollen um
eben impfstoff uns abzusichern
aber auch das thema das man immer wieder
mit maßnahmen kommt für einen monat zwei
monate drei monate
das erleben wir jetzt wieder mit der
notbremse die menschen sind mittlerweile
perspektivlos in vielen bereichen jetzt
in unserer industrie noch ganz gut aber
es gibt natürlich andere bereiche in der
wirtschaft wurde schon angesprochen
hotellerie die gaststätten der
einzelhandel auch natürlich kunst und
kultur in denen herrscht wirklich
perspektivlosigkeit und ich glaube
aufgabe einer regierung ist es eine
strategie zu entwickeln einen plan zu
entwickeln diesen plan umzusetzen und
den menschen leitlinien zu geben wenn
wir in unseren unternehmen keine
strategie entwickeln und die menschen
leiten
uhren zeigen wo es hingeht dann wären
viele betriebe würden heute nicht mehr
existieren es ist planlos kopflos und
zum teil wirklich dilettantisch gemacht
danke herzlich herr wolf und ihnen noch
einen schönen abend und ich möchte
schließen mit der runde frau schwesig
frau federle und herr weiler ich weiß
nicht ob sie es wissen sie haben eine
ganz wesentliche ganz einschneidende
erfahrung alle drei in ihrem leben
gemacht sie haben in den vergangenen
jahren in kurzer zeit eine
krebserkrankung alle drei vorläufig
mindestens vorläufig überstanden
vielleicht sie frau schwesig wie sehr
hat sie das geprägt in ihrem umgang
jetzt mit der korona krise sie haben es
vorhin selbst einmal angesprochen hat
das den blick noch einmal geschärft
verändert oder hilft es möglicherweise
sogar etwas ja gefasster etwas leichter
vielleicht sogar mit dem thema corona
umzugehen
ich würde nicht sagen dass es leichter
ist aber ich weiß was es ihnen bedeutet
ja auch gerade jetzt risiko patienten
für patienten die jetzt auf ihre tumor
op warten was es bedeuten würde wenn die
verschoben wird und deswegen wir dürfen
nicht allein den blick haben dass kurve
patienten behandelt werden müssen
sondern es gibt eben leider den
herzinfarkt den unfall
die krebserkrankungen weiterhin und für
mich ist die maxime dass wir
sicherstellen müssen dass gerade die
lebensbedrohlichen krankheiten weiter
gut behandelt werden können das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt das heißt nicht
dass wir nicht auch gucken müssen dass
es keine nebenwirkung folgeerscheinungen
gibt zum beispiel was auch angesprochen
worden ist bei den kindern aber
natürlich erlebt man während einer
solchen therapie und mit solch einer
erschütternden diagnose auf demut und
weiß wie wichtig es ist um die
gesundheit zu kämpfen und dass man das
nicht alleine schafft ohne tolle pfleger
schwestern ärzte und vor allem ohne die
hochleistungsmedizin hätte ich es nicht
geschafft das habe ich nicht vergessen
und ich möchte einfach dass es auch
jedem bürger und jede bürgerin weiter
zur verfügung steht
federle was können sie aus dieser
einschneidenden erfahrungen
negativen erfahrung anja erkenntnisse an
kraft vielleicht auch ausziehen für
ihren kampf in der korona krise also ich
bin natürlich dankbar dass ich am leben
bin und das ist die medizin gibt und ich
sehe sowie wie eben gerade auch schon
gesagt wurde das große problem ist ich
bin ja auch notärztin ich merke das oder
ich habe auch eine praxis ich merke dass
die leute weniger zum arzt gehen dass
die herzinfarkte die patienten die
herzinfarkte am länger warten bis sie
anrufen und das sind manchmal minuten
entscheiden
deswegen mein großer appell an die
menschen keine angst zu haben nach wie
vor bitte die vorsorgeuntersuchung
durchführen und nach wie vor bietet
sofort wenn sie irgendwelche beschwerden
haben die auf 14 fahrt schlaganfall oder
sonst irgendwas zeigen bitte sofort den
notarzt holen weil wir haben auch da die
zahlen sind deutlich runtergegangen und
wir haben auch daten riesenproblem über
das kaum einer redet und insofern das
ist ganz ganz wichtig ich persönlich für
mich ist ganz wichtig meine familie hat
mich unheimlich gestalten hat mich auch
in der ganzen corona pandemie eigentlich
hatte ich mir vorgenommen nicht mehr so
viel zu tun aber mir ging es so wie hin
frau schwesig ich bin da reingerutscht
zwei jahren und man kann ein corona und
ich bin einfach ausleihen und seele
ärztin und dann habe ich halt angepackt
und ich glaube aber den mut kann anderen
auch machen es funktioniert und man auch
wenn man krebs hatte oder auch das hat
man kann damit leben und kann trotzdem
was tun und es geht trotzdem weiter
ja ganz tolles gespräch mit ihnen ganz
kurz noch eine weile auch sie haben
diese persönliche erfahrung gemacht dass
gerade schon gesagt und ich sehe sie
heute abend ganz gesund wie viel kraft
haben sie auch aus dieser erfahrung für
die korona krise für sich ausgezogen
also einmal erstmal vielen dank an die
jetzt vor allen dingen auch eine an die
pflege hat die in wichtigen teil haben
und da wünsche ich mir einfach dass man
hier
mehr sensibilität für gerade die pflege
rechte und krankenschwestern und pfleger
hätte es müssen wir brauchen mehr
pflegepersonal die laufen alle laufen
alle wirklich auf den augen
im letzten gleis die haben sehr viel zu
tun haben keine freizeit mehr da es viel
und vor allen dingen was sie auch
möchten die pflege anleger dass sie
näher am patienten sein können und wenn
ich zum beispiel ein freund familie
liegt jetzt im sterben hat krebs der
würde vielleicht auch gerne paar leute
um sich haben was nicht sein darf also
ist schon ein einsamer tod den mann dann
stirbt und das finde ich ganz ganz
schlimm
bei mir ich hab das hoffentlich
überstanden klar die untersuchungen
kommen immer wieder man hat angst oder
nächsten untersuchen das ist normal da
zustand aber wenn ich die sehe für die
es keine hoffnung mehr gibt den wünschte
ich mir ein bisschen mehr freiheit auch
wenn die pflegekräfte das wollen dass
sie näher an die patienten kommen damit
das sterben nicht so einzelnes danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für diese am ende
persönlichen ich finde durchaus
bewegenden worte auch gegenseitig in
dieser runde danke manuela schwesig lisa
federle und albert wyler in der runde
die nachdenklich und persönlich geendet
ist und so streitbar begonnen hat sie
haben über ihre persönlichen ängste am
ende gesprochen und wir haben anfangs
gestritten über die ängste die man im
moment ertragen muss wenn man hier und
da laut seine meinung zu corona politik
gesagt und das haben wir hier in der
runde beschlossen das darf nicht sein
wir wollen weiter streiten egal ob wir
das gut finden oder das gut finden
herzlichen dank dafür an diesem
sonntagabend und einen guten wochenstart
ebenso
[Musik]